en principio el bolívar cobraron
venezolano de una moneda
destruida alguna moneda que perdió sus
cualidades como dinero y que bueno en la
actualidad era muy engorroso de realizar
operaciones con dicha moneda producto de
la cantidad de cero y el colapso que
estuvo generando los sistemas
administrativos y contables la
destrucción del bolívar que ha sido el
resultado de la nefasta política
económica del régimen de nicolás maduro
el desastre en materia monetaria que
colapsó los y el sistema monetario
venezolano como todos conocemos tenemos
prácticamente ya por cuarto año
consecutivo inmerso dentro del fenómeno
de la hiperinflación lo que hace que
esté el alza exacerbada de los precios
en venezuela ocurre el minuto y el
segundo tuvimos unos años muy de muy
alta inflación especialmente en el 2018
donde según las cifras oficiales superó
al 130 mil por ciento pero en definitiva
la economía venezolana ha transitado con
niveles muy altos de inflación de 6 y 4
dígitos en diferentes años lo que bueno
ha motivado el bolívar no cumpla sus
funciones como medio de pago como
reserva de valor ni como medio contable
o medio de cuenta entonces es muy
difícil realizar operaciones en
venezuela con monedas una moneda
destruida lo que incluso dio paso al
fenómeno de tener un régimen multi
moneda con mayor presencia del dólar en
alguna en algunas regiones del país
vemos la presencia del peso colombiano
como instrumento de pago y como medio
transaccional y en otras se han
utilizado este en minerales para
realizar el intercambio en definitiva
tenemos una segunda reconversión de la
administración de nicolás maduro nada
más y nada menos que de boro en 3 años
aproximadamente 11 0 y eso dibujó un
tanto lo que es este
el colapso de la economía venezolana en
términos de la destrucción de su sistema
monetario luís l quisiera preguntar
también creo que es suficiente esta
medida zona no debería ir acompañada de
otras
en esta reconversión es una simple
sustracción de 60 es una medida que no
nos viene acompañada de un plan
económico esta está esta reconversión no
viene no da respuesta a los problemas de
fondo de la economía venezolana carece
de un plan económico que le acompañe y
que pueda atacar los problemas como
decíamos este presente es de fondo en de
manera en el área monetaria en el área
fiscal en el área cambiaria que están
presente en la economía venezolana es
una simple operación cosmética que nos
va a dar respuesta a los problemas de
destrucción del poder adquisitivo no es
una medida antiinflacionaria no da
respuestas a los problemas
inflacionarios del país y como
comentábamos solo viene a resolver
problemas en los sistemas
administrativos contables a tratar de
facilitar las operaciones en esa moneda
y en los sistemas de las empresas que
vienen colapsando el sector bancario el
sector comercial venía ya esté eso
solicitando la necesidad de que se
tomarán algunas medidas porque sus
operaciones es contable estaban
colapsadas prácticamente claro son
inoperantes que se han convertido una
moneda de muchísimas gracias